alright so safe to say a lot of things
happened at comic comic Thor talk
Avengers revelations pen stabbing so one
of the things that I found particularly
awesome was the announcement of a street
fighter tekken crossover fighting game
yeah that's real now Capcom's making
this street fighter tekken crossover
fighting game using the street fighter 4
engine who are we kidding us like the
best fighting game engine ever and what
a concept a crossover fighting game that
doesn't have to be compromised or nerfed
take notes I mean honestly this is
awesome ever since street fighter 4
Mortal Kombat marvel vs capcom 3 and now
this is like the return of the fighting
game genre and namco also announced a
tekken vs street fighter cross over that
they're going to produce which is the
same basic concept only that one's going
to use the tekken fighting engine and
that's what I think makes this crossover
project particularly unique because no
one gets left in the cold you like
Street Fighter we got you you like
tekken we got you everyone's happy if
you like both when you'll probably have
to do the Harvey Dent thing to decide
dammit I like street fighter and when
asked about the official release date
the official release date is not for a
while I mean is that like a general not
for a while like not for a while give or
take a week good give my mortal kombat
time to stake its claim mind it deserves
it a seriously street fighter tekken
crossover this is gonna be awesome
because everyone loves a good crossover
but you can sit here and have me blob
about it forever or you can click the
link below and it'll take you to the
gameplay footage which I think was shot
on a cell phone but it was still badass
so what do you guys want street fighter
vs tekken in the street fighter engine
or tekken vs street fighter in the
tekken engine and if you say neither you
are lying don't lie to yourself comment
below let me know because you know this
is awesome